la creciente tensión entre rusia y
ucrania centra la reunión de cancilleres
europeos reunidos hoy en bruselas ha
hablado un poco de conferencia con el
secretario de estado norteamericano
anthony blinken para hablar de las
negociaciones con rusia y muy
especialmente el encuentro que mantuvo
anthony blinken con su homólogo ruso la
pasada semana en el ginebra la unión
europea insiste en que se la debe tener
en cuenta ante cualquier decisión por
ello mantiene todos los canales de
comunicación abiertos aunque moscú sobre
todo insiste en seguir negociando con
washington fuentes diplomáticas aseguran
que aunque la tensión es palpable lo que
hay que mantener sobre todo es la vía
diplomática pero si falla esta vía la
unión europea insiste en que quiere
enviar un mensaje de unidad y de que por
que ante todo estarán preparados para
que haya sanciones económicas masivas
contra rusia existe mucho secretismo
sobre cuáles van a ser exactamente estas
medidas estas sanciones pero los
ministros prometen que estarán a la
altura de la en circunstancias y que
también estarán preparados ante planes
de contingencia por las evidentes
consecuencias económicas que puede tener
también para el bloque europeo en
cualquier caso la unión europea insiste
en que igual que ocurrió con la invasión
de crimea en 2014 actuarán con rapidez